3h-20 on en vient à la guerre en Ukraine
la Maison Blanche agite le chiffon rouge
elle se dit bientôt à cours d'argent ce
sont ses mots et presse le Congrès
américain de débloquer une une enveloppe
de 100 milliards de dollars 100
milliards pour Israël mais aussi donc
pour Kiev toujours sous le feu russe la
nuit dernière les ukrainien ass sur
avoir déjoué plusieurs attaques
aériennes dans les régions de rerson et
de mikolaiv Emmanuel Chaz on vous
retrouve en direct de Kief bonjour à
vous la menace reste réel pour les
civils
oui tout à fait et vous mentionnez
Julien mikolaev et hson Helson qui est
particulièrement sous le feu des
bombardements et ce tous les jours je
parlais il y a quelques jours à Helson
avec le porte-parole de l'administration
militaire régionale Alexandre
tolokonikov et il m'expliquait que c'est
très difficile pour la population tout
simplement d'éviter ces attaques puisque
je vous rappelle que les trouprus sont
juste de l'autre côté des rives sur
l'autre rive du fleuve niplo donc à
l'opposé de Helson donc il y a très peu
de distance entre l'artillerie russe et
la ville donc c'est pour ça que lorsque
la ville est bombardée et ça arrive
plusieurs dizaines de fois par jour et
bien il y a souvent des victimes civiles
alors hier des bombes russes sont
tombées sur deux hôpitaux à hson ainsi
que sur des résidences des des immeuble
résidentiel aujourd'hui c'était sur une
école maternelle une femme à de57 ans
était blessée aujourd'hui donc on voit
que cette population ukrainienne n'est
pas du tout à l'abri de ces attaques en
plus des bombardements durant la journée
il y a évidemment les bombardements
durant la nuit de drone de missile avec
la défense antiaérienne ukrainienne qui
affirme avoir à nouveau déjouer une
attaque de masse sur les villes de
Helson et de mikolaev et je rappelle
enfin que sur le front la situation est
extrêmement difficile justement sur
cette rive occupée du fleuve niplo où
les Ukrainiens ont effectivement réussi
à s'implanter mais à quel prix et bien
on ne sait pas exactement mais en tout
cas on sait qu'il est très très élevé en
homme et en matériel et ceux des deux
côtés ça rejoint ce que le commandant en
chef des forces armées ukrainiennes
Valérie zalogen disait en novembre dans
une interview à dit Economist que on en
arrivait finalement à un moment de la
guerre où à forces égales et bien il n'y
avait c'était très difficile d'avoir de
voir des avancé justement sur la ligne
de front merci Emmanuel Chaz en direct
de Kiev pour France 24